القمه الابرز ستلتئم غدا في مدينه باليه
الاندونيسيه وتجمع الرئيسين الامريكي جو
بايدن والصينيه على هامش قمه مجموعه
العشرين بعد عده لقاءات افتراضيه ومكالمات
هاتفيه يستعد الرئيسان للاجتماعي وجها
لوجه للمره الاولى منذ الوصول بيضا للبيت
الابيض الرئيس الصحفيين انه دائما نقاشات
مباشره مع نظيره الصيني وهو ما منع ايا
منهما من الفهم الخاطئ ل نوايا الاخر وشدد
على انه سيتحدث الى تشي حول الخطوط
الحمراء لكل بلد على امل على امل تجنب
صراع
سيدخل زعيمان القمه بنفس جديد ربما يعطيهم
دفع الى الامام فالرئيس الصيني فاز بولايه
الثالثه بينما خرج بايضا من الانتخابات
التشديد النصفي ليتنفس السعداء بعد ما
تجنب موجه اكتساح من المعارضه الجمهوريه
الرئيس جعل التنافس مع الصين في النواحي
دبلوماسيه والاقتصاديه والعسكريه وكذلك
التقنيه محورا رئيسا لسياسته الخارجيه
التي اعتبرت الصين اكبر تهديدا للولايات
المتحده ومع ذلك دعم بيضا محادثات بشان
مجالات تعاون ضيقه مع الصين وحتى قبل ان
يبدا الاجتماع لا يبدو ان اي من الزعينين
تراجع عن خطوطه الحمراء في مجالات مختلفه
فتايوان جزء من الصين
وستعود بالقوه عند الامر بحسب الرئيس
الصيني في ما قال الرئيس الامريكي في
الثلاث مناسبات ان الولايات المتحده
ستدافع عسكريا عن تايوان اذا هجمتها الصين
صحيفه واشنطن بوست قالت في مقال في مقال
تحليليه لها ان الصين تريد اصلاح العلاقات
مع الولايات المتحده لكنها لن تتخذ الخطوه
الاولى واضافت الصحيفه ان اصلاح العلاقه
بين التكين وواشنطن سيتطلبوا اكثر من مجرد
اظهار حسن النوايا وسيحتاج اتفاقا اتفاقا
على الجوانب الاساسيه لهذه العلاقه
[موسيقى]